from now on I'm actually going to try
and stream as much of the roller coaster
tycoon let's play recording for
timelapses as I can so that does mean
that I'll be able to produce more of
these videos in a sense because and then
because well up to now I would have
either streamed or recorded for my let's
play and sometimes it was a really tough
decision to choose one of the two I I
still don't really know why I never
decided to do both at the same time but
that's basically what I'm going to try
and do in the future from now on as much
as I can because you know it's fun to do
some streams but it's also it's also
important to keep making those videos I
suppose and they're both fun to do so
why not do them at the same time it's
also a lot more efficient the only real
downside to it is well for one the time
lapses are a little bit less
concentrated as you can see i'm kind of
going all over the place and usually
it's not too much of a problem because i
try to do the streams alone and not ma
group of people talking because you know
that is kind of distracting but other
than that of course you get things like
technical errors in the streaming like
last time nightbot died a couple of
times and if you don't know what is that
is a program that allows you to that
allows people in the street into a
request songs that the stream will then
automatically play and then afterwards
twitch world band my video because
copyright but and whatever and it just
died and stuff like that might always
happen in the time I've send that means
that the time lapse isn't as great as I
maybe wouldn't like it to be and
sometimes you know people will come into
the stream and ask hey can you show off
the park a little bit and I'll do that
but I won't do any quick povs or any
anything like that so I do have to kind
of find it compromise between the two
things but yeah what I'm working on
right now is basically this it's it's a
temple ish building it's got the
classical elements in it obviously and
those amazing Ralphie sets because I
just love those things too much but I
decided that hey this is that park with
the this joke is getting all to theme so
I decided to just get some of that as
well and I opened oh and what's that
thing called again station Jim's pookie
I think that's the name but well he's
got loads of spooky sense anyway I
opened all of those things because
they're good and tried placing all of
those objects and actually making a
classical building with all of that
stuff and actually turned out to be
really nice and I was able to get some
nice details in the building that I
normally couldn't because Ralphie SATs
don't quite have some of the pieces that
station Jim sets offer especially if
there are like seven of them so that
that turn out to be really nice I still
do want to add a couple of details to
that but this is pretty much what I was
working on in this time lapse and there
was there was something else which i
think i forgot i there was some foliage
work and also working at spinning at sea
of our thing I don't even know what to
call that thing but just generally
making the park look better because
obviously some of the things that I've
been skipping up to now is doing placing
things like park maps here and there the
holes where you put all your goods when
you go and enter a ride small things are
basically the things that I'm skipping
in favor of the larger things but those
things are still obviously going to have
to be done so that's also stuff and then
there's the interior of this building
which I don't even know why I really
bothered with that because as soon as I
answered everyone was like in game thing
twister scrambled eggs and yeah I'm
sorry the idea behind this was some epic
ignore flat ride prep perhaps even in
the dark with loads of effects and stuff
like that but I just placed that thing
over there as a kind of dummy so I could
have something in the building but I'm
not really going to work on anything in
it I just wanted to fill this area with
a billing because there was nothing yet
and this this was really the only thing
that I wanted to what I could kind of
place in that room over there and you
know I didn't want to build the
thousandth building without a purpose
because everything needs a purpose I
find like what what did a gendarme Smith
say again I don't know without purpose
there's no purpose purpose neo mr.
Anderson and what that's basically on I
love that guy seriously he's amazing
that's off topic oh yes finds this this
was just that that moment when I
realized that adding vines to all of
these buildings make them look so much
better and at some point I think I went
vine crazy and I still need to do that
with the park as a whole because this
part doesn't have nearly enough fines
because if you want something to like
dilapidated but also really awesome and
adventurers and spooky at the same time
and basically all of those things vines
are something that you can often use and
it actually turned out to be really
handy for this facade as well because as
you can see this facade is placed very
close to that swinging ship or is it was
swinging rotating something ship and the
problem with that is although it does
look good and that's the reason why I
built it like this it is way too close
to the ship and if I only plays 13 next
to those buildings the ship is going to
crash into the tree and you know that I
like my trees so this is of course a
catastrophe for me but then it turns out
that i can get the greenery in the
buildings with fines as well so that's
really nice and i suppose a building
doesn't have to be a ruin or completely
overgrown by nature to add vines to it
helped some buildings that are built in
the real world have fines too and I'm
sorry about that jump cut I think that
was actually a jump cut from one stream
to another stream and then there were
also jump cuts from my crash to starting
up the game again and at some point
fraps didn't have any room to record
anymore because fraps is amazing I've
got a hard disk of one terabyte and fill
it up every time with fraps recording is
because they're pretty big yeah it's
kind of unfortunate that there
uncompressed in that sense but yeah
that's something I just have to put up
with I mean the quality is really good
though and which is something that I'm
not too sure if I can really say that
say that about this facade the thing
with this is I've set this before but I
feel like it's getting old the theme in
general
and all of the buildings look very
similar of course each time I try to add
some new elements but there is very
obviously one well certain style within
the park as a whole and there are no
different areas with a different theming
there are some slightly different areas
in center that you have got the mountain
range I've got the castles in the more
spooky area but it's still very similar
in that sense and I actually don't know
if I've talked about this earlier on but
in the next park that I'm going to do
for my let's play yeah I think I told
this in the stream but not yet on the
video but in the neck in the next park
of my let's play I'm actually going to
try to divide the park over multiple
Park files so it's not all going to be
built in one park file like I'm doing
right now but rather I'm gonna have
different sections with different themes
and put them in different Pike's as well
and then well quote unquote pretended
like it's one point now that might sound
very stupid but it's actually something
that I greatly recommend people to do
and it's an idea i think started off
with hath hath and i don't know if he
still likes people to calm that I I'll
call him HS designs just in case and
basically he's got a pike kingdom of
Legends think that's name yeah but it's
a beautiful park but it's um built in
many different park files with one part
file for each theme and the reason he
did that was because he has a crappy
computer but it's really an excuse that
he doesn't even have to give because no
computer in the world even nozzles
computers aren't probably able to run
roller coaster tycoon 3 in a huge park
well like that seriously it always
crashes so I can't blame him for doing
that but that's something that I went to
try next time because it means i can
build better Pikes and it almost feels
like starting off with the new Pike
every time you build a new section so
that's really something nice that I want
to try but that'll be for the next
season and now I need to head over to
the next episode and it's this is it for
this episode so see you in the next one
also I'm not going to cut this video
because I keep cutting videos and before
it they actually
and that's a problem that I definitely